hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar new viral and
non-viral platforms for t cell
engineering novel delivery and gene
editing tools for cell and gene therapy
applications I am Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by laberd's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it brought to you by thermal
Fisher Scientific a world leader in
serving science whose mission is to
enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increased laboratory productivity to
learn more about thermal Fisher and the
solutions they offer please visit thermo
Fisher comm let's get started this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
C button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speakers obviates milord
is your PhD the director of R&D for cell
biology and transfection at Thermo
Fisher Scientific Xavier works on
creating and improving nucleic acid
delivery for research and therapeutic
applications he identified new DNA
delivery approaches for hard to
transfect
cell lines and primary and stem cells
and he's the inventor of lipo
threatening 3000 xavi A's team is also
focusing on new delivery solutions for
crisper delivery new scalable lentiviral
production systems mechanical delivery
approaches for primary
she sells in nvivo delivery of RNA I and
mRNA for research and therapeutic
application he studied molecular biology
and plant physiology at the University
of Montpellier through in France and
received his PhD in human genetics from
Clemson University
Xabi a thesis work involved identifying
the genes responsible for split hands
split foot malformation 3 his
postdoctoral research fellowship was in
the laboratory of dr. Michael G
Rosenfeld at UCSD where he studied the
roles of micro RNAs in pituitary gland
development
Sal BA will now begin his presentation
all right
thank you Judy and thank you everybody
for joining this webinar today I will
talk about new solutions viral and
non-viral platforms that we designed for
t cell engineering and really help the
field of cell and gene therapy and
really the situations that we're facing
right now is we see a new therapy being
developed and using cell or genes as a
therapy and we see this the demand is
growing there the results have been
really phenomenal and now did this
really need to better manufacture those
products and that SEMO Fisher we're
really committed to provide the best
platform solutions to enable cell engine
therapy now one of the issue is the
current commercial manufacturing process
of our vector productions is actually
unfit to meet the growing market demands
and really around the the scale and the
volumes that we need to develop for cell
and gene therapy we need to make sure
the processes must maintain biological
activity answers stable charging
expressions and prevent transmission of
infectious disease while complying with
strict regulatory guidelines and so the
challenge is really around design
platform technology that can enable
efficient and inexpensive upstream and
downstream process and inexpensive is a
key word here we want to make solutions
that make cost efficient so those
therapy can actually be applied to many
many patients
really our commitments now this webinar
is really focused around t-cell therapy
specifically and this slides really kind
of show the complexity of manufacturing
t-cell therapy it's not as easy as the
small molecules or reselling we've seen
antibodies there's a quite more complex
system and right now still filled on a
cellular lot small scales and really the
challenge is in the next few years is
how can we scale this up how can we
manufacture it yourself in in in the
robust fashion so they can actually be
used widely as a therapy in the process
if you look at t-cell therapy is first
you need right now is a lot of
autologous t-cell therapy so you need to
prove to get the T cells from the
patient's there's a selection process to
select the t-cell to separate the t-cell
from the B cells and other cells in the
blood and then there's a big engineering
part in the middle when you want to
genetically modify those T cells so they
can actually specifically Express a
receptor I can then recognize the cancer
cells which is the key aspect of this
therapy you net you then need to expand
those T cells in large amount and then
finally fuse them back in the patient's
so you can see that there's a lot of
processes and manipulations of the cell
that that can be done right now at the
lab scale but really we want to kind of
be able to scale this up this webinar is
really focused in the middle here which
is what are the ways to better activate
and gene transfer and to better engineer
those T cells so I'll focus specifically
on lentiviral prediction system that we
developed but also the new generations
that we see coming which is
electroporation device as well as gene
editing now we also have a lot of
product in the other area isolations and
beans and I'll talk a little bit more
about this in the next slide so now
that's another way to look at this
workflow you see we look at cell
isolation and activations cell
engineering like I just talked about
cell expansions where there's a lot of
needs for new media
replacement growth factors and as well
as signalers technology wash field
finishing cryo this is also a very
important area you want to make sure
those cells sterile and clean and
produce on their GMP conditions so they
can be safely injected in patients and a
lot really than characterization there's
a lot of characterizations and QC all
along this process to really make sure
that the cells you're trying to inject a
pure they don't contain contaminants and
they're ready to use and so there's a
lot of safety identity functional
analysis cell analysis protein and
genetic now within thermo Fisher we have
a lot of those products already and I'm
not going to list them all but kind of
give you an idea of some of the key
product that we have in this area for
example cell isolation and activations
we have the dynabeads
that are produced by our colleague in
dyno up in Norway and those beads are
actively used to actually either isolate
the T cells but also to grow and expand
the T cells and actually some of those
beads already use in a clinic to prepare
the T cells in a sound hearing out this
is where I focus mostly so I'll skip
this and set extensions we have media
that allow you to grow your immune cells
and T cells specifically such as the m5
media optimizer and also we do a lot of
custom media to kind of depending of
your needs we can specifically
formulated media for your needs
optimizer and teeth are used right now
in the to expand t-cells we also have
human serum replacements which allow you
to get away from using human serum which
can be costly not very robust a lot of
our abilities so we you know get rid of
this variability by having a more
defined serum placements and they can
also work we're also developing growth
factors CTS what we call CTS is really a
cell therapy system so those products
are the highest quality standards and
not only GMP but they also have extra
quality to really
maintains best quality possible-- for
the cell therapy we have a lot of
different growth factors such as
interlocking two four and seven will set
the last single use technology so those
are the bags the bioreactors that you
can actually use to grow yourself so we
have bioreactors we also have a rocker
reactors and that allow you to grow
yourself and watchful cryo we have
products such as cts PBS but also
cryopreservation media and then on the
characterization in safety we have a lot
of molecular tools that can be used for
this such as qpcr or next-gen sequencing
with the higher turn platform or for
that a meter with a tune NXT we have a
lot of product in solutions as well as a
lot of antibodies to do a lot of
characterization so really kind of a
kind of overall you know set of tools to
to to be able to do those gene modify
t-cells workflow we're really like I
said the focus is as around cell
engineering and specifically to start
with really the lens of our production
system so lent you t-cells are their
hard transfected you can't simply use
the transfection regions and you have to
use a virus and in this case
lentiviruses is kind of the preferred
method to transform those t-cells
because not only do you need to
introduce the DNA inside the cell but
you also need that DNA to get introduced
into the genome of the t-cells so the
t-cells can express for a long time the
the camera can't agenda receptor that
you're trying to express at the surface
because what's important in with those
therapy is is once rejectors modified
t-cells into a patient's you want us to
sell to stick around for a long time so
they can actually do their job which is
booming unto the cancer cells
kill the cancer cells but also remain in
the body so if any new cases all appear
they can actually get rid of it so it's
important to have a sustained expression
of this receptor and lentiviruses are
really perfect for this because they
incorporate the DNA inside
now making plenty vs. is not easy you as
you can see on this slide on the left
side what you need to do is you need to
use the packaging cell lines so
typically those cells 2 & 3 cells a
chicken and three cells if you need to
trust X into them different vectors 1
vectors contain your gene of interest
which is on the left
whatever gene you want incorporate and
the 3 vectors we have on the right are
the packaging vectors so you need to do
a transaction of four different plasmid
DNA transfect into the stew and three
cells then the reverse will be released
by the cells in the media and then you
need to harvest and purified and and get
the cell via now if you think about it
you know you've you injecting millions
and billions of T cells and for each T
cells you need at least two or ten
lentivirus lentiviruses to be able to
transistors T cells so you need a lot of
lentiviruses now what are the challenge
is a lot of the system on the market
right now are using a different system
meaning the cells the packaging cells 2
and 3 cells are sitting on the bottom of
the dish and neutral victim logic as you
can see on the upper right you use a lot
of petri dish to do this and changing
the media works great for for the small
scale of the research scale but if you
try to scale this up you become a
challenge because you need this either
in surface and we have like cell
factories that are stackable last place
that you can grow a lot of cells at the
bottom and if you want to go even
further now we are walking incubators
and really kind of those giant e cell
factories that you can use for that play
factoring but it's a problem you can
imagine first they hard to scale because
there's a lot of plastic involved and
there's a lot of manipulations that can
be really heavy and also some of the
system contain serum and and and really
overall and then low titer so because of
the low titer there are too
and they become very expensive and and
you know the whole t-cell therapy
workflow they can't represent 40% of you
cost and that's the big problems and and
and really the goal that we want to do
in this system is really reduce the cost
of relenting our productions to really
help and fulfill the needs of this
market now so here I'm talking about the
new product that we launched which
caused LV max we're not really new in
this in this business there's some of
our products are already being used on
the market such as Aleppo victim in 2000
CD for example which is used as a
transaction reagents to make
lentiviruses
so some company already using it and
they are using this product to make
large-scale commercial grade LV
productions that are actually used in
your clinics and so if you look at let
your production system here this last
kind of does the first part which is the
vector constructions you know you want
to clone you gene and do what kind of a
molecular put different promoters or
kill switch Exeter acid so this we
really use the power of our one of our
group in Germany called gene art which
are gene synthesis company and they can
do all you they can fulfill all your
chronic needs and allow you to clone
your vectors in terms of vector
productions like I said there's a lot of
people using till adherent system right
now but really our goal is to move to a
suspension system that allows you to get
you know more scalable system and and
and really overall we just look at the
cost and I will talk about it today but
we also downstream of this we have
another group that's focusing on vector
appreciations and you may have heard you
know brain like Poros capture selects
the affinity mattresses and what those
guys doing they actually develop
affinity mattresses to 35 viruses and
purification can definitely be a
challenge you can lose up to 50 percent
of atlanta verse through the
purification process
and we really try to improve this with
more smarter system affinity mattresses
that allow you to kind of a better as a
light you you viruses and scallop and
scale it up so right now we have
mattresses for AAV eight and nine and
this group is developing new mattresses
for lentiviruses
so if you interested please contact us
and we can definitely put you in contact
with this group but let me focus on the
middle here which is really around
vector productions and also a few words
about the a different system so like I
said it's a lot of iron system on the
news right now and so we thought a lot
of other system actually use older
generation cross section systems such as
calcium phosphate or P I that worked to
some degree but what we wanted to show
here in this work is showing that by
simply switching the transaction regions
to two thousand or even to our best
restriction which is the perfect I mean
three thousand you could actually really
higher yield and allowing you to get a
lot better titers and overall obviously
lower the cost and this is slide kind of
showing this some examples when we use
two thousand three thousand and you see
a lot better yield so yes the
transformation may be a little bit more
expensive than P I to start with but
because you get such poor attackers the
overall cost of ulv is actually will be
lower so if you interested if you don't
want to move your system if you want to
stay in an ideal system you know we
simply suggest that you may want to try
to swap just the transaction region so
you'll see better Tigers we have an F
note on our website about this kind of
detailing the protocol on how to do this
really the focus here is we wanted to
radically change the process and most
importantly we wanted to adapt the
process to be in suspension suspensions
allow you to really scale this up and
and kind of overall reduce the cost of
the manufacturing so to reduce the cost
though you need to have really high
titers so we wanted to develop a system
that does not lose the titer actually
even better than endurance in general
adaran cells are easier to transect
to see pretty good titers and once you
move to suspensions because the cells
are in suspension they have a lower cell
surface membrane surface and they be
hard to inspect and you can lose some
titers the our requirement was really to
get titers at least equivalent to
adherent and even better scaleable
obviously because the suspensions you
can now take them from a shaker flask to
bioreactors and ultimately we want all
of our product to be GMP media cell etc
so they can actually be used to the
clinic let me say a few words about this
so the way we attack this system in this
problem is we look at the system
approach you know a lot of people trying
to optimize the lentiviral productions
they buy cells from different companies
different media different restrictions
and cos try to figure it out put this
together well pretty much did the same
but at other large scale meaning we
wanted to optimize and find the best
cells for these applications we wanted
to screen and optimize the best
transection reagent for this
applications we have a lot of experience
through the in vitro gen Dale in life
technology we have a lot of experience
in transaction regions since 1987 so we
have a lot of region that can be
specifically designed for this
applications we also wanted to find new
and answers and new supplements and so
you can see there's a lot of different
factors from cells from sections media
supplements and so we use here design of
experiments to really optimize each
components so not only identify the best
cells but also make it work together
with the other components and so that
design of experiment was very useful the
goal was to get a system that is a high
titer their height are more than 110 to
the 8tu per ml and this is
unconcentrated and the title is a
functional titers in which we transduce
cells and and count the soldiers cells
so it's not qpcr scalable that's the key
factors in the end GMP so the
can actually be using the clinic so let
let me show you our approach what we've
done in the lab to really design these
products that we call get Co LV max and
kind of showing what we've done in the
lab here so you can see on the Left we
we needed to screen a lot of different
regions you know different cell lines
different transfection different media
and supplements so and all the in
combinations at different ratios so
there's a lot of experiments to be done
here so really to be able to do a
massive screening of all those
components we use in 96 well dip well
plates so that's that's the beauty about
suspension cells you can actually use
deep wells and check the cells in each
well and allow you to do a lot more
combinations and it's once we find the
leads and new products we then verified
into shaker flasks first moving at 30
meld NC productions then 2 1 liters and
now we in in the process of verifying
the protocol in really adapting to
lockers platforms such as the wave of
bioreactors and I can say all that
titers were functional on HG 1080 cells
a lot for the cleaning we'll use a lot
of GFP as a readout vectors and flow
cytometry to really look at the titers
so now let me select I say this is a
system so LV max contain cells media
supplement and answer introspection
region so it's all you need to produce
the LV what I want to show you kind of
in the next few slides and each
component of this case so first we have
the cells those are cell like I said
that tune and 3 derived they can go in
there high density and stay healthy for
a long time so it's important and in
suspensions so those cells you can
actually achieve up to you know 13 or 14
million cells per male so they're very
high density without losing viability
and that's very important also those
cells you know do not aggravate or clog
which make it very adapted for
developing high density system like this
and this is showing here that the growth
curve with the viability and upper left
and you can see those cells can grow
very fast and and very healthy in a
suspension environment so you have to
sell now something that is underlying
everything is not only as isolating the
right cells but also the right protocol
for example even though those cells can
be grown in 12 million per ml you can
imagine that high-density we achieve the
transaction will actually will affect
the transaction efficiency so you need
to really find the right balance of the
right density to have the maximum
productions but also the right density
to have a maximum transaction you know
you can have 12 million per mail but
it's taken transfect and you you're
gonna have actually overall less you can
end up having less lentiviruses then if
you start with lower concentration so I
won't go throughout these slides they're
kind of showing all the the optimization
that we've done and working on the
protocol to really allowing our
customers to have their the same result
that we see in a lab and so there's a
lot of work being done on the protocol
level to really kind of optimize each
parameters and guarantee your robustness
in this system now the other thing we
looked at is the supplements media and
the supplements is a system that we use
to allow us to control the growth of
those cells the last thing you want to
have the cell to grow too fast because
when they grow too fast actually spend a
lot of time multiplying what you want to
do is really slow those cells down so
they can actually spend more time
producing what you want them to produce
and and it's a phenomena that you we use
a lot for protein production so it's
kind of similar for lentiviral
productions
when you want to slow down the cells in
such a way so they can actually maximize
productions if you slowed them too much
and you slow down the machinery too much
and therefore they want producing our
viruses and here the slides show this on
the upper left we use different
concentration of the supplements 1 5 and
10 percents and you can see by this you
can achieve the cell growth and if you
curate the cell growth
we have the tighter production which is
at the bottom left you see that we can
find optimum concentrations to really
maximize many of our production now I
notice that because it's multifactorial
there's a lot of components come into
play this is where design of experiment
is very useful notice this experiment is
not as simple as using supplement at
different concentrations
there's also cell density being involved
as well as the amount of DNA and
introspection regions and as well the
passage of the cells a lot of
multifactorial variables and you need to
consider and look into in the context of
all those different regions you know
this so self supplemented solar cells
but also transection is very important
and in the past you know my group we've
been developing transfection reagents -
we try to develop transmission region
that works on many many different cell
lines with many payloads kind of a broad
spectrum reagents in this case though we
can be a little bit more specific
because we go specifically after one
cell line specific we can control the
conditions better and we know we need to
transect for plasmid so transect in
cells and suspensions is is this
typically more difficult then and there
in cells because like I said before the
membrane surface is different but also
the density can affect and in also
translating for different plasma can
also be a challenge so here we we went
back into a library of regions we have
accumulated a lot of different
components compounds over the years and
really squid specifically for this
applications where we we went through a
lot of different reagents translating
for different plasma into the cell lines
they really try to decide the best
transcription our region possible and
here this is an example of a do iran and
you could see different codename for
different restriction reagents and you
could see we added quite a bit of
translation region that were performing
better now obviously this is what we do
in the lab to squint
we do for the kids we only pick one put
in the kitchen and recommend this one
and and so like I said before there's
also a lot of underlying work to
optimize the protocol and years showing
kind of a little bit of a sample of the
type of things we do in the lab so not
only we need to select the best
transcriptions but once we sell I get
the translation we need to optimize the
protocol and this factors that are
important such as the eluding the
transcription reagents in an OP TMM the
time of incubations can address ticket
back home transaction efficiency you can
see here on the upper left if you
transect if you dilute into Optimum's
you have about one to two minutes to
then process proceed with complex
assuming with DNA because you will
quickly lose activity if you leave it
too long in optimum so really you know
accumulated incubation in nazi mm is
critical for the reagents for DNA on the
right it's the less important you could
see the DNA is a bit more stable than
optimum so you have a little bit more
time all the other additions also
matters although in this case it doesn't
matter too much but we're also looking
at this as well as the the complexation
mix and the time you can incubate in the
stability of this complex so i don't
want to spend too much time on those
graph and the details the you know when
i want to highlight is we try to
simplify a protocol and give you
guidelines i'll to do it but you can see
behind this protocols i mean that may
look simple there's actually quite a bit
of work that we're done in in in the
back to really kind of optimize the
conditions and not only making for the
best performance but also the most
robust way so everybody can have the
same result that we get in the lab
another aspect reagents we went after to
improve lv transduction lv production is
an answers there's an answers you can
use that allows you to actually
the self to release more Atlanta verses
in the media and to improve the budding
out of lentiviruses and here again
there's a lot of different components
you can look and this is where design of
experiment is very useful but here this
is a result of a screen you can see
again all kind of different candidates
here compared to a control which would
be no one answers you can see we find a
lot of different end answers that can
drastically improve the titers of the
cilenti versus you can see we can easily
achieve you know one point five to ten
to the eight lentivirus per ml again
this is not diluted so I get a lot of
questions is you know if those
enantiomers are concentrated or not they
are not we just simply take mental verse
from the media we do say I own delusions
and transduce HD 1080 cells and then
measure the titers by flow cytometry so
you can see a lot of improvements they
are on tamil titers and coming from the
in answers so again we do a screen in
the lab and then we pick one that we put
in a kit I'll skip a little bit on this
one but again you can see different the
time of additions can matters we tested
you know whether you put at the same
time you knew the transcriptions or four
hours later six hours eight hours now
the nice thing is you actually have a
longer window between 4 and 16 hours you
need to add the in inserts to have the
right activity and I kind of important
for the protocol which is on this slide
here where we want to give you really
the best protocol most robust to achieve
your performance so we recommend to see
the cell that 3 million per ml now one
issue that we've noticed here is people
count the cell differently there are
different machines that can give
different counts so sometimes there's
more variability there so it's important
to kind of be consistent there so if you
don't see the exact resolve what we see
you may want to kind of change a little
bit of density around two to four
depending of the way accounting then you
would simply add the supplement at the
time of the transaction so you slow down
yourself then you prepare the complex
you do the transaction
reagent user transection region you
prepared a complex you had 10 minutes to
the diesel said 10 minutes to deliver
itself and then post restrictions you
have their answers and then you could
have it 48 to 55 hours now this slides
kind of show the progress that we've
done through LV max you could see
prototype zero it's kind of where we
started where we took regions from we
did what a lot of people do which with
different reagents
commercially-available assemble them and
and and and see what we get you can see
that's what we started put it at zero
and through optimization of each
components and and working the protocols
together we can now achieve you know in
the healthy max regions results as you
could see on the right
achieving in this case fact is six ten
to the eighth
this is this isn't done in 96 well plate
we tend to see better titers in 96 well
plates we're not sure why they're
probably because of the mixing but we we
definitely achieved at least you know
one more two to ten to the eight but you
could see a really nice improvement
through optimization of each reagents
and what can get together now this slide
slide 22 really highlight the importance
of a system because it's not just about
this airline it's not just about the
transactions it's about the combination
of all those things and how they work
together so yes we selected the best
talent that we could the best
restrictions the best answer and the
best supplement so making them work
together it's actually part of the major
optimization and development that we've
done and here showing this in this
swapping experiment with you we're
showing that if you change LV 3 and 3
with 2 & 3 freestyle for example you can
see you're going to lose quite a bit of
activity of
Nancy verses from spectral regions you
know I would hear there are the perfect
I mean regions are more expensive than P
I which is true they are but it's really
not about the cost of the regions the
cost of the linty of our productions so
yes you may you may use the cheaper
transmission regions but what's gonna
happen is you're gonna have a lot less
titers and if you look at the price per
tighter then you are going to end up
spending a lot more money to produce
healthy and it also you'll be more in
the next slides supplement are very
important and in sirs are critical and
they really kind of show that if you use
them all together in the protocol then
this is where you can achieve the best
results now
it's scalable and that's the key really
aspect of this this because it's
suspensions you can actually do 96 deep
well plate which is great if you want to
do a lot of lentiviruses and screen and
find out which one is the best which car
is the best for your t-cell then you
could do a lot of research this way but
you can also take this product all the
way up to the chain and moving to
bioreactors so here showing different
shaker flasks but also now we're working
with our colleague in finesse to really
develop two leaders and even plus you
know bioreactor protocol to really kind
of take it to the next level and be able
to do 200 to 500 liter scale and this is
important so in this line we really
wanted a product that you can use from
your R&D to the clinic so you don't have
to change your protocol along the way
you don't have to change the region's
and and let me aspect ultimately may
affect the performance you can actually
you know do small scales that are
throughput non GMP open platforms you
can do a lot of lentiviruses and then
slowly move up to the clinical aspects
of preclinical you can use medium scales
and in clinical buy directors and so
ultimately we want a kit that can do
large scale low throughput and GMP and
in by directors I should mention that
the kid right now Andy coil T max some
components are GMP but not all of
and we're working towards making all the
components GMP and this should be some
complaints will be available sooner than
others but ultimately the whole kit will
be available next year as a full GMP
version it's not kind of highlighting
the price I guess like I said before we
hear the p i-- is the cheaper reagent
test transactions which is true but
because you actually get typically ten
to fifteen times less buyers the cost of
lv end up being fifty to fifty eight
percent more and in it's easy to imagine
especially if you move to different
scales if you need a certain number of
lv 4 delta particles for you needs let's
say if you use p i-- you will need for
example with ten liter batch but if you
use lb max system you will only need a
one liter batch so you can imagine there
the price difference in terms of media
and cell and cost and people in time
that really news at the end of the day
you said money and this is really the
goal of this product the goal of this
product was to reduce the cost of
manufacturing lentiviruses so actually
everybody can use this therapy and
develop t-cell therapy so this is the
kids like I said it's a system that has
media supplement high density new
translation and answer all together and
and and really worked out together this
product has been launched in July 2017
so it's available now we have different
formats and it really is the first
optimized native our production system
so we've done the work for you we
selected the best region for each and
then put them together and now like I
said before it's animal origin free
scaleable serum free and we get really
high titers and the GMP is coming the
full version of this kit will come next
year but if you interested that we have
some you know media for example there
are already GMP we have different
configurations we have the standalone
that comes with the cells in the media
so if you need to order more media or
more self we have the starter kit this
is what we recommend to start which is
really
sorry which is really as everything you
need the cell the media transfection
region supplement and insert and then
separately we offer also the transaction
kit that as a trance fiction region the
supplement and n answer separately
so this is the catalog number
I think receiver really kind of going
our website am officially comes last
lentiviral and you'll have more
information here now in the next in the
next ten minutes what I want to show you
is a little bit kind of what we see in
the future and what's going to happen
the specifically focusing will be more
non-viral options so lentivirus is
really the main platform right now and
it's probably it's going to be for many
years works great deliver t-cells but
ultimately what we like to develop is a
non-viral solutions whereas you can use
electroporation as well as gene editing
to allow you to stable incorporate the
DNA's at the genome and and and really
kind of going from lentivirus or slash
retroviruses to generating apertures one
other limitation of livers like we
mentioned here is the cost and we try to
reduce this with a better system like LD
max the safety this concern about you
know because the Lenti incorporated the
DNA inside the genome that's concerned
that that DNA can incorporate into
existing gene and change the function of
the cell to look at a traumatic effect
this limitation around the insert size
there's a limitation of the size you can
put into the lentivirus to incorporate
and as we see this field is moving
toward a little bit more complex system
you know more subtle regulations of the
chimeric antigen and so that may be
limitation there what's important you
cannot do gene editing so for example
works break for total system allergenic
you're going to need to do knockouts and
so for that you're going to need to use
a gene editing approach to knockout
atisha receptor so you can have
basically a donor they will be able to
give this to yourself to
patience and kind of develop allogenic
so what we see is really the next
generations will be a nonverbal approach
using gene editing approach that will
allow you to do knock out knock in and
in really incorporate now what's lacking
now is probably around the tools exist
but we want to make them the performance
we need to improve knock on efficiency
knock in and and really avoid a V as a
donor DNA so the question is simple
lynch averse Cantrell's yourself t-cells
from 20 to 45 percent insertion can we
achieve the same with an envelope
approach and this is really one of our
focus as well and really our goal is
beat energy versus so we have tools for
this so first it's done with the
delivery tools we have neon
electroporation device which is the
device that allows you to simply electro
Pro itself and and it's very easy to use
you have a pipe header and the tips is
basically the cadets so you simply type
that the cells put in the tips and then
you could control the parameters such as
the pulse width the pulse size and the
number of poles to they allow you to do
transactions and on the right here we've
done a lot of optimization in primary
t-cells where we look at all kind of
factors that the donor variability the
activation protocol the media we use and
what's interesting is if you look on the
right we can achieve 80% restriction
efficiency in primary t-cells which is
pretty remarkable and the lingual cells
are very hard typically they're hard to
translate what's interesting and we
don't know fully know why but you can
see a day 3 you get 80% but they five
day seven they ten through you know
expansions we if they become more and
more difficulty transects so that's
something with actively exploring the
good news is we could already achieve
80% a date screen which probably will
really help our gene editing experiments
when we can put DNA at that at that
stage and be able to engineer t-cells
now the other part that you need
is the gene editing tools and for this
we have we have a lot of genetic tools
and basically two categories one are the
CRISPR Cassadine tools that we offer in
different format I'm sure you all heard
about CRISPR you know this system they
use a guide RNA as well as the protein
to basically go recuva nails into the
genome inside the genome so cast so
basically what you need to do gene
editing you need to express the protein
gas 9 and you need to have a guide RNA
they find each other and then they go
recognized on a genome and allow a
specific gene specific besides specific
cuts so that's different way to bring
the cast and protein inside the cells
you can bring it as a protein itself
which is the RNP format you could bring
as an mrna format or DNA format and you
know I can talk for a long time about
this but to say simply we found the
protein format is the most effective one
gives you the best results but also the
minimum of target effects because the
protein is there through the cleavage
and then quickly disappear
we also guide RNA and synthetic guide
RNA that's something that the team just
came up with those guide RNA are can be
chemically modified to improve stability
but the most important is a single guide
RNA you complex for the protein and then
you deliver we also just launched a new
cast 9 protein we call to cut cast 9 and
actually give you even performance
that's the CRISPR tools we also have
tout to tell effectors
so those I'll work liver differently
they are protein the DNA binding
proteins and there's a specific code and
you could design tau2 to target specific
excites and the beauty of this is you
designed a thousand and you could put
infusions all kind of proteins that
allow you to do make the DNA or at you
can either
presser activator to turn on the genes
what's nice with the system is you can
actually have the two protein they will
work on as the genome and if you put a
restriction enzyme fused to those towels
once they recognize they will work as a
dimer and then cleave the DNA so towel
allow you to actually give more
specificity because you must have the
binding of the two towels and you must
have the perfect pairing between the
talent or cleavage and then porta
factors to it specially if you want to
move commercially with the system the IP
landscape for CRISPR is a little bit
more confusing that the different groups
working on caste 9 and it's unclear we
really truly own the IP so of clinically
there might be a problem
Talon we have a clear commercial path we
only the only provider of talent
technology and we can actually give you
full access to develop commercially it's
also I give more flexibility there's
less restriction on the sequence you can
go after to kind of give you more
flexibility but again we have both
system available what we've been
focusing a little bit more is really
around our and PCAST 9 as well click the
guide RNA and so what we wanted to do is
kind of use this tool in optimize so we
have a lot of offering in T cells
relations and activations and so this
kind of see here's the protocol we would
get T cells and activate them using a
dental beads we do a transactions with
the gene editing tools and the neon
transactions and then we can verify in
DL and cleavage efficiency using our
sequencers or iTune flow and here kind
of showing some experiments that we look
at cast 9 RNP delivery in d 3 t cells
you could see on the top the protocol we
use different sites we go either after
better acting or hprt just as a control
site you verified and then here we are
showing a gene cleavage
on the jail but you could also do thank
gene sequencing but really the goal of
the slides kind of show you this new
cast 9 that we call true cred cast 9
showing the better performance with this
cast line and you can see here on the
bottom the cleavage efficiency that we
already achieve which are pretty
remarkable with the all cast 9 we were
achieving 70% 60% now with the new way
up to 80% 90% are those locust and neon
program mean we use different programs
different pulse or system but kind of
showing the robustness of this platform
and really achieving regularly 80 and
90% knockouts on those primary t-cells
it's pretty remarkable you on hprt locus
we see even better improvements with the
new cast 9 where the old we're giving
about 50% we can achieve 80% so you can
see we can already achieve in primary
t-cells with electro pressure on
platform and there are new gene editing
tools we can already achieve a really
nice knockout efficiency here this is
another example instead of using HP RT
in beta acting we use TCR receptor and
we design multiple guys attractive on
track t2 t RB T 1 or T RB C T 2 you see
depending of the guide you can have
different activity which is that's why
it's important to really kind of screen
and find the best guide RNA so you can
see that in those T cells with some of
the guide we can achieve 90% and if you
do a functional knockout so that's a 90%
of Intel efficiency but if you look at
functional knockouts if you look at the
protein itself we achieve 99 98 % so
really incredible yield incredible
knockouts and really we don't see this
as much of the challenge anymore and
with the right tools we can already
actually very important knockouts
so that part is taken care of so first
you can really efficiently achieve the
knockout
now really the next step if you get a
replacement e versus how do you think
important to incorporate the DNA
T self so not only you need to cleave
the DNA but you need also to have a
little use for combination so the DNA K
incorporate the decided cleavage now a
lot of the methods right now our can
achieve 30 to 40 percent knockin one of
the problem though is you need to use a
v6 as a donor DNA so if you have a
combination of a a v6 donor DNA with
caste 19 editing electroporation and
then all together you can again achieve
knocking but it really doesn't fix the
problem because one of the problem of
lentivirus is the cost in producing it
and you know the manufacturing workflow
but now you were pissing Lentini to a v6
donors so it's really kind of it doesn't
fix the problem what we really want is a
whole non viral approach and so k the
the question is can we now replace a v6
donor DNA with a plasmid and that's even
all whole non viral and it's already
being done there's actually quite a bit
of papers showing that you can use neon
in this paper published by Alexander
Martin you see very nice incorporation
of the DNA inside its primary T cells
using neon electroporation about 25
percent there's another paper showing
against them platform neon gene editing
and it can also achieve pretty high in
corporations knock him into the HSC cell
so you see this is already working could
already use nonverbal but those two
examples really really using small small
inserts of DNA well for corty you're
gonna need more than 2 to 3 KB so it
felt kind of a bit of a challenge so I
can't tell you too much back in so we're
working actively on this so we've shown
right now that we can achieve a donor
DNA naked with the cast and put in the
spitter the new tool that we have we
could already achieve up to 2030 percent
knocking efficiency so we think we're
getting there
and ultimately reply cilenti versus it's
still a long way away but kind of
definitely work-in-progress and if you
interested please contact us so I'll
stop right here thank you for listening
this is really kind of summarizing the
sound engineering we have different
platform the most ready to you right now
and launch is really Atlanta verb
production system going deep go LD max
if you if you want to produce high high
level of nature versus strongly
recommend this platform and I'll stop
right here and I'm I'll take any
questions thank you very much thank you
so VA for your presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window so VA will be joined
by Ken Watanabe PhD and she knew
scientists three to answer as many
questions as time permits
Kim is a product manager at Thermo
Fisher Scientific her product portfolio
enables cell and gene therapy
researchers in their nucleic acid
delivery efforts more specifically she
is responsible for the recently launched
dip Co L v-max lentiviral production
system and the Invitrogen in effect
amine lipid nanoparticle platform for in
vivo gene delivery she's currently based
in Carlsbad California Sheen has been
with thermo Fisher Scientific for 15
years focusing on cell culture as well
as DNA RNA and virus delivery solutions
she has been involved in the development
of several innovative products including
nitrogen lipo fact amine RNA IMAX lipo
threatening 3000 and CRISPR Max has nine
transfection reagents more recently
Sheen led research and development for
the new get Co LD max lentiviral
production system she is currently based
in Carlsbad California and the first
question is for you
Xabi a I'm currently using an adherence
system for lentiviral production when
does it make sense to switch to
suspension production
yes okay it's a great question so if
personally I think it makes sense to
switch right away
I mean I Darrin system in the past it
used to be more performing the
suspensions and so it was kind of a
trade-off between having high
performance and in suspensions but now
with the system that we developed in
this new tools it doesn't make much
sense to use a different anymore and so
I think it's ready to switch and we have
a starter kit for this even if it's
small-scale now instead of using dish
you can actually now use 96-well plates
so I think it makes sense to switch
right now hey Darby another for you have
you done any experiments using LV max to
generate car containing LV instead of
GFP yeah so something I did not mention
during the development of this program
before we launched we actually have
active beta testing programs and so in
which we contact many customers or many
people that do lentiviruses and we give
them early access to those products and
it's very important for us to get the
feedback from those customer and then
other product works and kind of tweak it
and make it better
well the feedback can be overwhelmingly
positive very positive almost hundred
percent success of all the better
testers most importantly they were not
interested in GFP nobody is but they
wanted to test the gene of interest and
so after reproducing our data with GFP
they move to their gene of interest in
some cases they have really large gene
enough problems with other platform so
they were seeing this platform as a
platform for difficult genes and and
they they observed fantastic results I
mean they've seen 10 times better with
their gene that are difficult genes or
genes specifically for party so even
though we haven't done the work in the
lab our collaborator did and I've seen
really good results with it
better than what they were doing in the
lab to develop protocols for larger
skills and to leader bioreactors yes yes
and that's what we're doing right now
after developing each components we now
developing our scale protocol we have
now we have one for bio reactors and
I'll shown the slides that should
similar results we this is still ongoing
so we have this protocol available if
you contact us we'll be happy to share
that with you but we actually think for
bioactive we could get even better so we
keep working on this thinking improving
so stay tuned for further improvements
and contact us for the existing protocol
that we have okay and our next question
is for Tim and it is does the system
work for gamma retrovirus or AAV yes so
this system was developed and optimized
for lentiviral production however it
should also work for a transient gamma
retrovirus production and AAV although
some optimization may be required and I
know our R&D has developed a really nice
protocol and some suggestions around AV
production if you're interested please
contact us and we can share some
suggestions with you okay and this next
one is for you what primary factors
influence viral titer yield yes
Vespucci so the size of size of G H has
been included in truthful possibly the
effects of our yet as a music can use a
tiger as well if there are only focus on
the length of our production the most
important effect is establishing a third
suspicious our cultural always a follow
they were suggested a cell therapy to
split the cell and growth of cells never
let us sell over girl or stood them as
an opacity and the regularly normative
the cell viability is very important
also during the launch of production the
accuracy of a cell count the press the
way to make the NHL speculation complex
are the other two plan respects to
influences our viral titer okay well
thank you both for that I would like to
once again thank Joe VA for his
presentation and I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions if you asked
a question and we weren't able to get to
it our experts from thermo Fisher will
be following up on each question on an
individual basis we would like to thank
our sponsors Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on this EE button at the
bottom left corner and follow up process
to receive your credits this webcast can
be viewed on demand through April 2018
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye